サンプルベース量子対角化法、略してSQDは、Krylovと同様の量子古典ハイブリッドアルゴリズムだ
量子対角化KQD、VQEなどと同じ種類に属する。こうしたハイブリッド
アルゴリズムを使う際には、各アルゴリズムが量子コンピューティングと古典コンピューティングをどこで活用しているかを考えると有益だ。VQEは量子
circuit上で古典的に最適化されたパラメータを使って状態を生成する。その場合、状態そのものは量子コンピュータ上にある。ただし
目標状態を得るプロセスは、古典コンピューティングと量子コンピューティングの両方を組み合わせたものだ。
演算子の期待値は量子測定を使って計算される。
ただし、項を古典的に組み合わせる処理も必要になる。
一方SQDは、量子コンピュータを使ってハミルトニアンやその他の演算子を
射影できる有用な部分空間を生成する。ハミルトニアンはその後、完全に古典的な方法で対角化され、目標状態が求まる。n行
n列の行列上の固有値ソルバー問題として定式化できる、科学や産業上の
関心ある問題があるとしよう。さらにnが十分大きく、厳密な古典的対角化が選択肢にないとする。そのとき
基底状態の関連する特徴をすべて保ちつつ行列の次元を削減できれば明らかに有利だ。実際それが
古典的なKrylov法を含む多くの近似固有値ソルバーアプローチの目標だ。問題について、基底状態の形をある程度
合理的に推測できるが、問題を完全に解くには不十分だと仮定しよう。その
場合、目標基底状態の妥当な近似を多数測定できる。それらの結果から
基底状態の関連するすべての成分を含む計算基底状態の部分空間が得られる。
その部分空間に射影すると、関連する自由度を保持したままより小さな行列が得られる。
ワークフローは以下の通りだ。まず適切な
ansatzを選ぶ。より正確には、目標状態のサポートと一致するサポートを持つansatzを選ぶ。その意味については
後で詳しく説明する。次に、samplerプリミティブで行うように計算基底で状態を測定する。
そして、サンプリング結果を使って基底状態を含む部分空間を定義する。
次に、行列をその部分空間に射影する。最後に、射影された小さな行列を古典的に対角化する。
各ステップを、特に部分空間の定義に注目しながら詳しく見ていこう。
量子コンピューティング全般において、適切なansatzの選択は常に重要だ。SQDの場合、ansatzの選択が
サンプリングで測定される可能性のある計算基底状態を決定する。
真の基底状態は、計算基底状態のあるサブセットの重ね合わせとして表現できる。そのサブセットが
基底状態のサポートと呼ばれる。基底状態とそのエネルギーの良い推定値を得るには、ansatzが
基底状態のサポートにある計算基底状態への非ゼロの射影を持たなければならない。
この図は、使用中のqubit数で取りうる全状態が張る空間を表す。サポートが真の基底状態のサポートを含む
ansatzが必要だ。
基底状態がs_ground = 8 *
状態100 + 6 * 状態001という非常に小さな例を考えよう。
これは2つのベクトル100と001からなるサポートを持つ。ansatzがSNZOT1 = A *
状態100 + B * 状態010 + C * 状態001という形だとしよう。そのサポートは
3つのベクトル100、010、001の集合であり、基底状態の
サポートの上位集合になる。これは良いansatzだ。
今度は代わりにSZOTS2 = a *
状態110 + b * 状態011というansatzを選んだとしよう。
これは2つのベクトル110と011からなるサポートを持ち、基底状態のサポートと重複しない。
これは悪いansatzだ。
ansatzが基底状態の良い近似である必要は必ずしもないことに注意してほしい。ansatzは
はるかに大きなサポートを持っていてもよいし、ansatzと真の基底状態で係数が大きく異なっていても十分機能する。
この段階で、十分に動機付けられたansatzを使って量子コンピュータに目標状態に近い状態を採用させた。
ここに示すのはユニタリ結合クラスター型（UCJ）ansatzで、量子化学において非常に有用だ。
次にシステムの状態を測定し、各
qubitの崩壊した状態を表すビット列を得る。VQEのようなハミルトニアン推定には多くの量子測定が必要だ。これは部分的には
不確実性を減らすためであり、部分的にはハミルトニアンを構成する交換するPauliの群の数によるものだ。
サンプリング法でも多くの測定が必要だが、理由は異なる。ここでは、高度にエンタングルした量子状態に関与する多くの
計算基底状態を効果的にサンプリングするために多くの測定が必要だ。SQDでは、サンプリングされたビット列がシミュレート対象システムの
配置に対応する。研究対象のシステムが物理や化学における保存則のような絶対的な制約に従う場合、
測定された状態のほとんどは有効だ。しかし一部のサンプリングされた
ビット列は、ノイズやエラーにより無効または非物理的な配置に対応する。
configuration recoveryと呼ばれるプロセスは、こうしたノイズの多いサンプルをより正確な配置の集合に精製することを目的とする。
このプロセスでは、平均軌道占有数と既知の粒子数に基づいて
個々のビットを確率的に反転させることで新しい配置を生成する。
精製された配置は、ハミルトニアン射影と対角化のための部分空間を張るために使われ、
量子状態表現の忠実度を反復的に向上させる。
configuration recoveryの意味を理解するために、極めて小さな例を見てみよう。4つの分子軌道を表す
4 qubitの量子システムを測定し、量子プロセッサから以下のビット列を得たとしよう。
各ビット列は軌道の占有状態を表す。
占有が1、非占有が0だ。Qiskitでは最下位のqubitが右端に来る表記を使う。
例えば、1 0 1 0は軌道1と3が占有されていることを示す。これらの
測定値は教育的な理由のみで選ばれたものだ。得られた占有数は物理的なシステムと一致しない場合がある。物理的な文脈では、
システムの全粒子数が既知であることが多い。また、
測定された状態の物理性を判断するために活用できる他の保存則も存在する場合がある。具体的に考えるため、システムが
全粒子数n=2を持つことが既知だと仮定しよう。これにより、状態
ラベルに現れるべき1の総数がわかる。これをハミング重み制約と呼ぶ。
しかし、測定された配置の中にはこの制約に違反するものもある。状態1 0 1 0は物理的に有効だ。しかし状態1 1
1 0は粒子が多すぎ、全てゼロの状態は粒子が少なすぎる。ゼロ
個だ。これらの違反はシステムのノイズや測定の誤りによって生じる場合がある。元に戻す方法が必要だ。
少なくとも近似的な意味で、物理的に意味のある配置に。
これをconfiguration recoveryと呼ぶ。
ノイズのあるサンプルを補正するため、有効な配置の平均に基づいて、無効な配置のビットを確率的に反転させる。
有効な配置の平均から算出した、軌道占有数の平均を用いる。
軌道占有数とは、各軌道に作用する数演算子の期待値だ。これはSQDから生成された状態を使って
自己無撞着的に推定・精緻化される。例として軌道2を見てみよう。4つの有効な配置のうち2つで、
軌道2が占有されていた。これで期待占有数は0.5と求まる。
他の3つの軌道についても同様に行う。では無効な配置1 1 0に戻ろう。ビットを1から0に反転させて有効な配置を生成できる。しかしどれを反転すべきか？判断方法の一つは
各軌道の占有数と先ほど計算した平均値からの偏差だ。
各軌道の占有数と先ほど計算した平均値からの偏差を使う方法だ。
ここで最大の差異は軌道1の占有にあることがわかる。だからビット1が
1から0に反転されるべきだと予想できる。もちろん軌道2もそれほど差がない。そして複数の誤りが重なった結果である可能性も、どんなに低くても常に存在する。
この測定状態が同じ状態での複数の誤りの結果である可能性だ。
全ての無効な状態に対して平均からの最大偏差だけを選ぶのは最適ではない。代わりに、ビットは
ここに示した差の関数である確率で確率的に反転される。この場合
平均占有数から最も乖離したビットを変更するとしよう。すると1 1 0は1 1 0 0になる。他の無効な選択にも
同じ処理を行う。この場合、ビット1と3を反転させるとしよう。
この補正処理の後、このような新しい配置の集合が得られる。
この精緻化された集合を使って、忠実度を向上させるために平均軌道占有数を更新できる。今回の場合、新しい
占有数はこれらだ。
この反復的なrecoveryプロセスにより、ノイズのある測定値が物理的に意味のある
配置にフィルタリングされ、SQDにおける固有状態近似の精度が向上する。SQDのQiskitアドオンにはこのプロセスで
役立つツールがある。真の基底状態のサポート上の状態を適切にサンプリングできていれば、
このサブスペースに作用するハミルトニアンの部分だけを見れば
良い基底状態とエネルギーが得られるはずだ。自明に小さい4 qubitの例では、最初は2の4乗、つまり16
通りの可能な状態がある。サンプリングとconfiguration recoveryの組み合わせを使って、これを
関心のあるサブスペース内の3つの状態に絞る。真の基底状態のサポートを構成すると期待される3つの状態だ。
次に、そのサブスペースに完全なハミルトニアンを射影する。つまり、サンプリングで得られた
recoveredサブスペースの列ベクトルから行列Mを作り、行からM daggerを作って、M dagger HMを
図式的に計算する。これは、サブスペース内の状態に対応する行と列の
行列要素を取り出すことを意味する。強調された行と列がサブスペースに対応するものだ。そして
それらが重なる暗く強調されたボックスが、新しい射影行列として保持する要素だ。
関心のあるサブスペースを選び出したので、古典コンピュータでこの行列を
標準ソルバーを使って対角化できる。真の基底状態がサブスペース内の状態だけで構成されていれば、この
対角化は正しい基底状態と基底状態エネルギーをもたらすはずだ。基底状態のサポートの大部分しかなければ
近い値が得られるかもしれない。この射影ハミルトニアンの基底状態が得られたら、各軌道の
平均占有数を計算するのに非常に有用な状態が手に入る。
以前は、基底状態に近づくことを期待してansatzを使ってサンプリングした状態から占有数を計算していた。
しかしそのサンプリングによる各軌道の平均占有数が最低エネルギー状態の占有数に対応するという保証はなかった。
振り返ろう。計算基底状態のサンプリングがあった。configuration recoveryを使って物理的に無効なものを補正した。そして全てを使って平均軌道占有数を計算した。
基底状態はそのうちの一部しか含まないかもしれない。この射影ハミルトニアンの基底状態は真の基底状態ではないかもしれないが、
元のシステムの真の基底状態とは異なる場合がある。しかし、サブスペース内のrecoveredされた状態の
任意の重ね合わせで作れる最低エネルギー状態だ。この状態の軌道占有数はrecoveredされた空間の占有数から得られる
エネルギー以下のエネルギーをもたらす。つまりこの占有数は基底状態占有数のより良い推定値だ。
この新しい占有数を使ってconfiguration recoveryプロセスを繰り返し、収束基準が満たされるまで
反復できる。Sample-based quantum diagonalizationは
VQEのような他のnear-termアルゴリズムと比べて高速だ。よりスケーラブルで、サンプリングのノイズや誤りに対してロバストだ。
ただし、システムの真の基底状態のサポートへの射影が大きい良いansatzを準備する必要はある。真の基底状態について何も
わかっていない場合、SQDは基底状態について学習するために他の手法と組み合わせて使う必要があるかもしれない。
基底状態について学習し、反復的に近づいていくために、まず他の手法と組み合わせて使う必要があるかもしれない。
基底状態に反復的に近づくために。
SQDは古典量子ハイブリッドアルゴリズムの新興スイートにおいて重要な役割を担い、
有用な量子コンピューティングに向けた最大の推進力の一つだ。